meta's Twitter copycat isn't quite
living up to expectations days after
launching on July 5th engagement has
dropped off a cliff
time spent on the app declined 60 from
its peak a few days prior according to
the software company's sensor Tower and
this was during the first week of launch
similarly software companies similar web
reported threads daily active users
dropped from 49 million to 24 million in
a week it's even more disappointing
considering threads had the greatest
start of any social media app ever it
reached 100 million users in five days
surpassing even the rapid rise of chat
GPT
so what went wrong
while the initial interest may have
appeared promising it's possible this
was somewhat misleading one factor
contributing to The Surge of signups is
how easy it is to join I could easily
get my puppy onto threads by setting up
through her Instagram account with few
clicks of a button additionally threads
offers the feature of transferring your
Instagram followers directly onto the
new platform this could have Amplified
the popularity of threads giving a
skewed perception of genuine user
engagement another aspect that's
problematic is that you can't delete
your threads account without deleting
your Instagram account as well you can
deactivate threads but you're locked in
unless you choose to delete both and
privacy concerns are off the charts when
I compare the Privacy labels from
Apple's App Store I noticed that threads
gathers a lot more information than
Twitter including what's labeled as
sensitive info this includes racial or
ethnic data sexual orientation pregnancy
or childbirth information disability
religious and philosophical beliefs
Trade union membership political opinion
genetic information or biometric data
which includes fingerprints and facial
recognition data because it collects so
much data threads isn't yet able to
launch in Europe as collecting sensitive
information requires a higher standard
of legal consent in the EU meta's track
record on privacy is far from clean
Facebook is known for collecting user
data and allowing advertisers to Target
them besides the privacy concerns
threads has limited features unlike
Twitter there's no option of a home feed
just for people you follow though such a
feature is apparently in the works
instead the threads algorithm and pushes
content from people you don't follow
based on what it determines to be the
most engaging the goal is to keep you on
the platform for longer eventually
exposing you to more ads when ads come
to threads Additionally the inability to
view posts chronologically on the
timeline or search for specific posts
restricts the user experience the true
successive imitators typically comes
from offering an improved version of the
original product like when Instagram
took inspiration from Snapchat to create
Instagram stories Instagram added new
features such as the option to pause
rewind and fast forward through stories
something that wasn't available on
Snapchat at the time this enhanced the
user experience and Instagram stories
surpassed Snapchat's user base
threads however doesn't really improve
upon Twitter it mirrors Twitter it's
hard to tell them apart other than for
the missing features I mentioned earlier
metaseals pitch for Threads appears to
be that it's not Twitter
Zuckerberg has been trying to Brand
threads as a kind and friendly place
where politics and news apparently won't
be emphasized
however it's the back and forth on
politics news and controversial topics
that makes Twitter so compelling drawing
people in and keeping them engaged by
the way I'd be grateful if you followed
Muse think on Twitter Link in
description
Tucker Carlson's interview with Andrew
Tate has been seen by 92 million users
on Twitter Tate is a controversial
figure who is banned from the platform
prior to musk taking over a big reason
the SpaceX and Tesla CEO acquired
Twitter for 44 billion was because he
felt freedom of speech had been
restricted
Twitter has been bracing for more
competition about a week after threads
launched Twitter started sharing ad
Revenue with creators beginning with a
portion of the revenue you earned from
replies to their posts so Twitter is
trying to incentivize people to post
great content bolstering its appeal but
maybe there's nothing to worry about
will threads end up in the graveyard of
other failed meta projects like lasso
Facebook's answer to tick tock or hobby
its answer to Pinterest the huge drop in
engagement so soon after launch suggests
it's headed down that direction unless
the app improves but maybe this wasn't
about threads but a bigger plan
threads could be part of Mark
Zuckerberg's wider goal to build the
metaverse a virtual reality space that
enables users to interact with each
other inside a computer-generated
environment
meta says it plans to decentralize
threats meaning it will work with other
non-meta social networks which aligns
with meta's vision for the metaverse a
seamless online ecosystem where
interactions are not limited to one
specific platform like Facebook the
Rivalry with Twitter is not confined to
the virtual world Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg may be stepping into an
entirely different ring possibly
fighting in an MMA Style Match who would
you place your bet on let me know in the
comments
as fascinating as this fight would be if
it does happen I seriously hope they're
not injured because their tech companies
really need their big brains the brains
behind their platforms are skilled
Engineers it's the kind of skill that is
so important to Foster especially today
that's why I highly recommend brilliant
a website and app where you can brush up
on your knowledge of math data science
and computer science interactively if
you're curious about how recommendation
algorithms work and how they predict
content you'd love dive into Brilliance
new how technology Works course using
brilliant is part of my daily routine I
like to go through their logic puzzles
which is a fantastic way to sharpen my
analytical thinking skills to try out
brilliant you can start with a free
30-day trial by signing up via my custom
link in the description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people to sign up through my custom link
will receive a 20 discount on Brilliance
premium annual subscription unlocking
all of the offerings thanks for watching
I'm Cindy Palm
[Music]